[inaudible]
Bridgette,
we've talked for about 35 minutes.
We have not said the two words.
Donald Trump.
First off,
I think we just had a record 35 minutes of conversation without saying Trump
once.
Okay.
You are a Trump supporter.
I'm a trumpet player.
Trumpets here.
Okay.
You're a Trumper tier.
I think you've met with the president,
right?
Yes.
Um,
how does,
well,
what can you tell me something about him maybe that the average person doesn't
know or that you might not get through the filter of CNN or that you maybe don't
even get through the filter of Twitter.
He is somebody.
He is a billionaire who left the life of luxury to serve the American people.
He is somebody who is not doing it for power.
He already had power.
He's not doing it for fame.
He already had fame.
He's not doing it for the money.
He already had money.
He doesn't care.
He wakes up every morning to all the insults and the hate and images of
beheading by Cathy Griffith that his son can watch and be mortified that
somebody actually really called my dad and then he remembers I'm not doing this
to please the media.
I'm doing it because I'm fighting for the American people.
They hate him,
not because,
um,
they hate him because he is serving the American people.
He is putting America first and they do not know how to handle him.
And that's why Donald Trump is resonating with a lot of people in this country,
from CEO's of companies.
The janitors working for $10 an hour because from the janitor to the CEO,
they know,
and everybody in between.
President Donald Trump is working for me.
And it's a breath of fresh air because for decades now,
we have had many presidents on the right than the left.
Not many people could say,
Barack Obama's working for me,
or George Bush is working for me.
Our Clinton is working for me.
But with Donald Trump,
the janitor knows president Donald Trump is working for me.
And that's why he's resonating with the people.
So when you see that
the,
the tweets and some of the over the top stuff,
you know,
every now and again I'll watch some old clips from him in the 80s talking to
Oprah or Phil Donahue and he's,
he's soft and,
and seemingly,
you know,
very pleasant and open and you can see the way in Q and A's with audience
members.
I think on Donahue.
He's,
he's extremely human.
All of these things and it's not exactly the caricature that we get these days.
Do you think that he sort of became this thing because it was the only,
he basically was the,
it was the only way he would have been hard enough to break through.
Does that make sense?
Like I think he was probably extremely similar to the person from back then,
but he became hardened because it was the only way were going to ever break
through.
There's like no one else was ever going to break through this thing and she
listened.
I asked that in a very convoluted,
but I think you got the point there.
Donald Trump today is the exact same person he was 25 years ago when he was on
Phil Donahue when he wasn't Oprah.
He still says the exact same words.
Have you noticed?
Well,
the theme is the same,
but he's,
he's hard in now.
There's like a,
and I don't,
I'm not even blaming him for that.
I think to go through this,
to go through the media machine and the establishment and all that,
you've got to get hardened.
Otherwise it will choke everybody out,
which is what he does fight to win.
Before they didn't argue with what he said,
so you didn't see that side of him.
He would've been just as hard back then.
Today they do not want to listen to any words.
He says if he became Jesus,
they would find a reason to fight against them.
They would call him,
you know,
evil,
Heiter,
monster,
whatever,
whatever.
So the reason why they call him all the names that they call him now is because
he has not toeing the line to them.
Look,
he has 90 million followers on Twitter.
He goes straight around the media.
He doesn't need the media.
He is communicating directly with the American people.
And the media hates this.
And he is somebody who fights the bread.
I love his tweets,
by the way.
You know,
and math makes a lot of people uncomfortable.
Oh my God,
I cannot believe he tweeted that.
You know what?
We finally have a man who stands up to the bullyism punches back.
We are so used to men who are whizzes in this country.
We have forgotten what it's like to see a real man who stands up and says,
I respect myself too much to let you walk all over me or call me that or treat
me that way.
But if you're treating me that way,
I'm going to punch you back.
Now stand up like a man in Fyc me,
we forgot how a man like that looks like.
And so Donald Trump is shocking the system at a time where men have been
stripped out of their manhood that you,
you know,
uh,
the society is changing,
you know,
roles are changing.
So in our society today,
they want the man that they can walk all over and you know,
they say,
oh,
we need somebody who is nice and you know,
like Romney or McCain,
you know,
everybody loved Mccain until he ran for president.
Then they did the same thing to him.
Everybody loved Romney until he ran for president.
They did the same thing to him.
I mean,
if you would hear CNN talking about Romney or McCain when they were running for
president,
they were saying the same thing.
He hated women.
All of those things.
I'm completely with you on that part.
Yeah,
that's what I mean by the,
the hardening of Trump,
that he almost had to be this thing because nobody else could have,
they tried it the other way.
They tried it with Knight,
you know,
nicer people,
so to speak,
and it just doesn't work.
So it's like,
well,
this is,
this is the guy you're going to get.
I had his getting things done and the American people are behind him and he is
resonating with the American people.
And if his message wasn't resonating,
he wouldn't have the tens of millions of followers that are following him on
social media and still rooting for him and the Donald Trump supporters there.
He'll even deeper with all the attacks from the media,
even the attacks from his own party,
they've,
I mean,
look,
you and I know there are people who hate his guts in Washington DC.
You talk about cleaning the swamp.
He is shaking everybody the left and the right,
despite all that,
his support,
his approval rating is at an all time high.
You know,
so it doesn't matter what people are saying to him.
He is doing what is right by the American people by America.
So what are some of the policies that he's doing that,
that Jive with this book?
Like in terms of borders and stuff like that,
you're,
you're for building the wall.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And here's why.
I am a legal immigrant to the United States.
I understand what it's like for people to want to come here.
I want it to come here so badly.
I remember getting an American flag,
putting it under my pillow and my bomb shelter and I couldn't wait to come to
America.
I learned English.
I don't know if I shared with you this was your last time writing subtitles on
my arm.
Did I tell you that's how I learned English.
I never studied English at school.
I was so determined to come to the United States that we would watch black and
white television operated on a car battery and our bomb shelter and my father
would watch the news and if there was any charge of the battery left,
I would watch the love boat on Wednesday night and Dallas on Friday night.
And you know,
we,
we would have every sub title.
I know,
I know that the button downs that,
that,
that's what impacted my life.
And,
and if two people looked into each other's eyes and you know,
he said something to her and she said maybe and they would write to us.
Maybe we met on the bottom.
I knew that maybe meant whatever that word in Arabic.
And I would literally write it in ink on my arm.
And because we barely had water to drink,
let along shower.
We showered once a week.
I felt a huge vocabulary on my arm.
That's how I learned English because I was so determined that if I ever meet an
American,
I want to be able to be able to communicate with them in their language so I can
get to the United States.
And when I came to the United States,
uh,
I came to America by marriage.
I had married an American war correspondent in Jerusalem.
We came to America.
We put in my papers to become an American.
I flew here,
I paid for my airline ticket,
paid for my attorneys to do all my paperwork,
paid for my doctor's visit to do all the needle poking to make sure I'm tested
for this disease and that disease to make sure I'm not bringing anything to the
country.
And then I had to study at two inch thick book written by the daughters of the
American revolution about America's history and heritage and pass a written exam
as well as a verbal exam in English before I became an American about America's
history.
By the time I became an American,
I knew more about America's history than my own American born husband did.
I am a legal immigrant.
Those are the type of immigrants we need coming to America because we had a fire
in our belly to be all we can be as Americans right now.
The people who are breaking the law to get here,
not because they want to come here for a better life or they are escaping
persecution.
Look at the caravan that's coming to the United States.
Mexico offered them asylum.
Mexico offered them jobs.
They didn't want it.
They're not there to save jobs or asylum that you n they best literally by you
and center set up specifically for those who want asylum and claiming refugee
status.
They didn't even stop continued coming to the United States,
to the border and not even to the port of entry.
Just to break the law to get here,
we have to have law and order in the country.
So yes,
I support Donald Trump.
Build a wall and make sure anybody who wants to come to the United States can go
through the proper channel and earn the privilege to be an American because it
is a privilege because people like me who did it by the book are insulted and
offended when we see criminals are allowed to come in here and have the same
rights that we paid with our sweat,
heart and blood to get and work very hard for years to become Americans.
Yep.
That's so fascinating to me because they've also done plenty of studies on this
where recent immigrants are actually against the caravan and against a lot of
playful,
not because they have anything against the people,
but if you did it the right way,
right?
If you did it the way the law lays out,
well then you don't want people to just just storming over and that's,
that is what a nation of laws is
so.
Right?
And you don't,
when you look at what the legal immigration is costing the United States,
do you know that $45 billion a year leaves America from those illegal aliens
that come here to work in the United States,
that illegal criminal aliens and they sent it to their countries of origin.
That money is not staying here.
They're not here to become a part of the American fabric,
to contribute to American society,
to grow,
to become all they can be.
They are here to use our system and siphon money and send it out there.
Do you know that it cost the American public $200 billion a year and welfare
expenses by criminal illegal aliens to the United States?
Uh,
3 million illegal aliens are incarcerated daily in American prisons.
30% of federal inmates in federal prisons are illegal criminal aliens.
So when you look at the cost,
when you add all the costs,
and I can rattle in a bunch of points,
but when you add it all up,
$338 billion a year is the cost of illegal immigration to the United States.
The cost to build the wall is nothing compared to what we're paying annually and
a left illegal criminal aliens.
Not to mention the crimes killing our children.
Ms 13 gangs coming here and what they're doing to our society.
We don't want any of that.
What do you make of the same people who will tell you that America is an evil
patriarchal capitalist,
that monster that also want open borders to apparently share in that Har with
everybody else?
America Pretty,
pretty flawed.
There wouldn't be.
Absolutely.
America is the most incredible nation on the face of the planet.
Look,
you traveled the world.
You're traveling on a speaking tour.
I was born and raised on the other side of the world.
I understand.
I've seen you and I have traveled the world.
I mean from Australia to Europe.
I mean we've been on a lot of places.
You and I,
and we have seen how the other,
the rest of the world lives compared to the rights that we have here.
Look,
our poorest of the poor who are living on welfare,
have dishwashers in their government,
paid housing,
have heating and air conditioning,
have cell phones.
You know,
these are luxury items and many other places in the rest of the world.
Um,
even in developed countries that are considered luxury items,
this is what we give to people who are living on welfare in the United States.
So those who complain about America need to open their eyes.
They need to go to India,
you know,
to the slums of India.
They need to visit the Philippines,
they need to go to Vietnam,
they need to go to Egypt.
They need to see how the rest of the world lives and then come back to America
and complain.
A lazy way of thinking really.
Cause it's just easier to destroy than create.
So it's just easier to sit here after all of the hard one freedoms and tell you
how horrible everything is rather than actually fix anything but burning things
down.
It's a lot easier.
Right,
exactly.
Exactly.
And they,
uh,
and,
but no one's holding them accountable.
You see people like us and the old grade generation who really fought World War
II,
who are the veterans are still lying among us today who fought,
you know,
and the wards,
whether in Korea or in Vietnam or World War Two.
I mean now they're getting older and fewer and dying,
but their descendants.
So understand what America did to the world and the freedoms that we helped
spread around the world.
Look,
we didn't want anything from the Japan.
We conquered nation and then we gave them their freedom and then rebuild them.
Who does that?
We didn't go to Iraq because we wanted the oil.
We didn't go to Afghanistan because we wanted the oil.
We went there and started building schools on bridges for them to improve their
lives and left and didn't take any of the oils with us.
We want to improve the world and we need the fight right now.
Those Lazy American brats who are speaking ELLs of America,
who do not understand the America we need to come together,
organize and rise,
rise together in defense of America.
And that's why we need to come together and understand what we are facing,
how we are losing our country.
And this is what I get to a in the book.
You know,
I say,
how did we go from the stories of George Washington and the Cherry Tree?
I shall never tell a lie.
How did we go from that generation?
Do the ANTIFA thug.
So we're born and raised in America,
went to American schools,
paid for by our tax dollars.
Who believe you can cheat,
you can lie,
you can still,
you can show up with machetes,
uh,
you,
and,
and brass knuckles.
You can hit people,
you can block bridges,
you can destroy property and you feel justified doing it.
How did we go in one generation and one lifetime from this to that?
And that's why we need to stand up.
Those of us who are in the middle,
who America greatness need to come together and stand up to fight the protect
America while we still have a chance.
So what are the other Judeo Christian values that we need to be thinking about?
We talked about free speech.
What are the other bedrock principles that we need to fight back some of this
stuff?
Oh my goodness.
We need to fight to protect our language.
Yeah.
I explained something very easy to you.
You,
we cannot lose our language.
Language Unites People in one nation,
the English language.
Right now we are importing people from different parts of the world and we are
not making them learn English.
We are now have public schools that have 16 different languages that are spoken
in a public school and teachers will have to be trained to,
to speak a certain language to children instead of saying,
okay,
now you came to America,
I need to assimilate.
You need to learn English.
I know Spanish people who have been in this country,
Mexican people for over 20 years,
they still cannot speak English properly or they speak very little English.
That's not acceptable.
That's not what made America great.
We have got to enforce that English is the official language of the United
States and show domain,
so we welcome people from all backgrounds.
The immigrants that came to this country back.
The Jews that came from all over the world,
the Iris,
the Catholic,
they,
everybody,
they came to the United States.
They made sure their children spoke English because they wanted their kids to
become as American,
as Apple Pie,
as fast as possible to assimilate into the society.
We're not seeing that right now.
We are seeing,
uh,
in Detroit to call government office.
You getting called in Arabic,
you know,
and then you push like four for English.
First you got Arabic and then you've got Spanish and then you get this and this
and that.
That's unacceptable.
And people need to understand their power.
And my book at the,
at the end of every chapter I have a section titled Dries Up and act.
No matter what I'm talking about,
I give people ideas and tips.
Three things you can do under 10 minutes that will make a difference for the
country and you can do them sipping your cup of coffee,
any or pajamas at 7:00 AM in the morning to give you an idea.
Yeah,
calling your elected official.
Many people say,
Bridgette,
what is my voice going to count?
My elected official needs to hear from 40,000 people before they do something
wrong.
I talked to elected officials all the time and I ask them,
how many people do you need to hear from about a single issue to make it your
top priority?
You'll be shocked.
How many do you think?
I mean it's gotta be so ridiculously low because nobody calls them and says,
you all think it's 40,000 but it's probably like 50 people or something.
That's it.
40 to 50 people and here is the science behind the numbers.
They believe if one person makes a phone call or writes a letter,
he or she are representing 1000 couch potatoes who feel the same way but are too
lazy to make a phone call or write a letter.
Yet they vote on election day.
That translates to 40 to 50,000 voters on election day that can make or break an
election.
So I thought people,
you can be active sitting in traffic.
I look,
we are in la.
How many hours do you spend sitting in traffic?
I spent two and a half hours yesterday sitting in traffic trying to go 50 miles.
Yeah.
Program,
the White House phone number program,
your elected officials phone number in your,
in your,
uh,
cell phone.
When you get a text alert from us about a bill coming down for about punch a
button,
click and call your elected officials or send an email of when people go to act
for america.org,
which I mentioned all throughout the book.
My Organization Act for America,
that Org,
they can click on contact congress,
they can sign up to get our emails and action alerts.
We send emails about bill's coming down for a vote.
The bill number,
who sponsors it,
what it says.
We even have pre written letters for them that they can email their elected
officials with the click of a button.
It'll go to your elected official,
um,
letters to the editors and script.
I give samples in this book.
The last chapter,
the whole chapter is samples about activism.
Samples about letters to the editor.
All you have to do is add your name and send it to your newspaper.
It's part of the problem that we put so much emphasis on the presidency,
so it's great.
You're doing local activism were saying call your Congress made if you've got a
problem with your exit.
My exit right here where I live,
I don't want to say exactly where it's filled with garbage.
For the two years that I've been living here,
David's been calling this guy nonstop to get the,
he wants to go out there and start picking up stuff,
but it's too dangerous.
But it's just,
but like nobody focuses on local anymore because we put such emphasis on the
executive branch,
on the cult of personality around the presidency.
So it's like by going to your local congressman or congresswoman,
you might actually get something done.
It's a lot harder to do it the other way.
Absolutely.
And I,
and on the local elected officials,
you know your local,
state and delegates,
I may have you called the guy at that,
the 12 people that sit and so this is why we started chapters nationwide.
This is why we have activists nationwide.
I thought people go to act for America,
that org sign up as an activist and join the chapter or start a chapter.
If there is no chapter near you,
everything happens on a local level because those local elected officials that
you develop a connection with an a contact,
go to become state elected officials.
I then federal elected officials,
attorney generals,
and then state senators,
congressmen.
This is how we change society.
And so I encourage people to get involved and become engaged in.
That's exactly what this,
this book is a roadmap for people on how thrice rise.
This is why we titled The tries,
you know,
are you selling the book?
We will need to get this book and they need to donate it to every library in
their communities.
So when people are looking to find out information,
they can find it.
Read it for yourself,
donated to a public library in your community,
get multiple copies.
We want people to learn how they can be mobilized.
The left understands how to mobilize.
We on the right,
understand the issues,
but do not know how to mobilize.
And that's what this book teaches them.
So what,
what else?
What else can we do?
I feel like he got a couple of other tricks up your sleeve.
Oh,
absolutely
sexy.
It can't just be calling your congressman.
Make new friends.
If
I find out,
start a chapter.
You'll get to meet great new friends in your community.
If people sign up to be a chapter leader with us,
we will connect them with the same group in their local community who sign up to
get our emails and they say,
I want to join a chapter.
I want to meet people in my community like this.
We connect them together.
They can do local activities together.
They can go out to dinners together.
They can work on issues relating to their community.
I have found I have made the best friends doing my activism.
That's what launched my career in activism.
So this is the type of ideas that people can do.
Come together and work together.
Have on a Saturday,
one Saturday,
uh,
have a meeting,
a chapter meeting once a month.
Write letters to your congressman about the garbage on the side of the street.
You know,
we need to clean this garbage out.
This is unacceptable.
Uh,
protests,
uh,
bills that are coming down.
I'll give you an idea.
We're accepting all these refugees coming in here.
Uh,
so right now we are bringing our standards down to accommodate the standards of
people from Third World country.
To give you an example,
the city of Denver in 2017 passed an ordinance that allowed people to defecate
on the sidewalk.
Why?
Because they have a lot of illegal immigrants who feel no problem to just drop
their pants and do it on the side of the road.
But because it is it reportable crime,
because that crime is punishable up to one year in jail.
And if you could put such a crime,
you are deported.
The city of Denver has a bigger problem with illegal immigration than San
Francisco and Philadelphia.
Hmm.
So that's why they passed the ordinance.
They did not want people deported.
Can you imagine if you have a chapter with 30 people or 30 people organizing
together on the same issue,
calling your,
their local state government saying,
this is unacceptable.
And if you don't change that,
we're going to vote you out and replace you.
That's how the left does it.
That's how we need to do it.
That's a pretty clear one where you could probably escape some of the cries of
racism,
right?
Cause nobody wants their streets filled up with pooper.
You know,
San Francisco has this app that'll tell you where human poop is
unbelievable.
And now the diseases that are spreading because of that,
and this is something I mentioned in the book,
all the rise in diseases in our country,
you know,
you've heard the right now about the Lyme disease or that disease that's not
being trend transferred to people because I in San Francisco you've got flies
basically eating that human waste and then you're walking down the street and
they're biting you.
Some mosquitoes now are transferring these diseases that were once eliminated in
the United States,
but it's simply eating human waste and I'm biting you with putting it in your
body.
This is exactly why.
About a month ago we started seeing,
you know this disease papa people cannot explain it.
Some people died.
Tuberculosis,
for example,
is exploding in the United States,
the top four states with tuberculosis or California,
over 500 cases,
Florida,
Texas,
and New York,
uh,
16 states are now grappling with tuberculosis.
It is the fastest growing disease in America right now.
They have,
the state of Wisconsin alone has 116 cases of tuberculosis and the majority of
them are drug resistant,
which means it takes six months to treat a patient and it takes six to eight
months to treat them at the cost of $150,000 per patient out of our tax dollars.
These are issues we need to talk about.
These are issues affecting our communities.
And that's what I,
what I discuss in the book.
So it's not only about national security per se,
it's why we need to rise up in defense of our culture and our freedoms and what
made America great.
Do you find that the people that are part of act are diverse politically?
Because it's so,
it's interesting.
I mean,
I've spent hours with you now and it's like,
I guess you're a conservative,
but you're not.
You're,
you're sort of my kind of conservative,
well,
yeah.
Your husband or your friend,
right?
Really,
you're like my kind of liberal,
which you,
which you know,
is half conservative at this point because everything is so upside down.
But do you find that you get a real mix of,
uh,
political views in the people that are coming to you?
Oh my gosh,
absolutely.
Look with our organizations.
I mean,
we have everybody,
people that put their differences aside and came together for the safety and
security of America and preserving who we are as Americans and defending our
American values.
Our members are Jews,
Christians,
Buddhists,
Hindus,
atheists,
gays,
lesbians.
I mean,
I've got gay chapter leaders,
priests,
chapter leaders.
We've got everybody,
people like you and I and everybody else that bought.
Yeah.
You know,
people may not agree on every single social issues,
but people agree on a lot of things that make us Americans because we love each
other as Americans.
We respect each other as Americans and we want to defend our country and the
principles that made it great.
And so that's why we work together.
And it's like I said,
it's such a shame that no people,
you know,
I never thought I would,
I,
you know,
I will be called the conservative or you would be called the conservative.
But you know what,
as far as the leftist concerned right now,
you and I are conservatives.
Yeah.
That doesn't matter that you are a married gay man.
You're conservative.
Welcome to the new conservatism and you know,
this is why would Donald Trump talks about nationalism.
We are in national this country.
We are,
we are standing up as a nation to fight w two,
what makes America Great Patriotic America.
You know,
the patriotism that we have in America,
they don't have another countries of the world.
You go to Australia,
you don't see the Australian flag flying everywhere.
You go to England.
You don't see that in British flag right away.
We noticed that when I was in your know that you're traveling worldwide.
Yeah.
What makes America so unique is this nationalism that brings us all together.
Our love for country people got the baseball,
um,
two games and we play the national anthem.
You know,
they don't do that in other parts of the world.
They don't play the national anthem before games.
We take it for granted.
I know everybody's upset with the president because he's talking about American
nationalism.
What brings us together.
They need to travel to Australia,
go to Canada,
go to Germany,
attend a football thing.
They don't play the national anthem.
It's not like the United States.
That's what he was referring to,
were talking about our nationalism.
What brings us together as Americans,
our Americanism.
He could have used a different word,
Americanism,
so the word so the left will not feel offended,
but that's what he was talking about.
Pretty sure they would've offended either way.
They would have been offended either way.
I feel I should give you the chance to close this with this speech as epic as
your last Po.
You've got about five of them here in the last hour.
Where do you want to give me a closing statement that will be memorable.
Footprints in history are not made sitting down.
Countries cannot be saved by hashtags and tweets.
We need to stand up and put some sweat equity into saving our country.
But thankfully we don't have to freeze and valley forwards like our founding
fathers in the snow waiting to see if we still have to have a country.
The next day we can do right now with our activism is come together and get
together at a coffee shop,
uh,
sipping our cappuccinos,
meeting like minded,
great American soul of America who believe in America's exceptionalism,
who believe in safe,
secure border hope,
believe in having law and order in our country who believe in respecting our
police,
who believe in honoring our military whole believe in cherishing the memories
and,
and acknowledging the freedom that we have at the sacrifices that our military
have paid to give us the freedoms that we have today.
You know,
when we visit other countries and you have visited France and you go to Normandy
and you see the graves of Americans and Normandy,
you sit back and you'll know that this American brave soldiers left their home
and went overseas letting the life on the line to fight for freedom and for
justice.
And for the American values,
if you don't want to call them Judeo Christian values and American values so the
rest of the world can experience the freedom that we have.
The previous generation was willing to cross oceans and go die over there to
protect the same freedoms that we have here at home and give them to other
people.
The least we can do is activate here and our home in the United States of
America and come together and stand together and face those naysayers and those
who slap labels on us,
at least they're not shooting bullets at us.
All they all,
they're saying he's a racist or she's a racist or she's a white supremacist,
but we can come together to save our country together.
And that's the beauty.
It's people like you and I coming together and looking into each other's eyes
and really being so excited to see each other again.
And we together again as Americans,
as different as we are.
But we come together and we love each other and respect for each other does to
save this country.
And that's what America is all about.
I encourage people to rise,
rise in defense of Judeo Christian values and freedom.
Get the book,
read it,
share it with their friends,
get multiple copies,
put them in public libraries.
We need to educate and go to act for America.
That Org,
by the way,
we named the organization,
act for America,
not think about America now,
which for America now pray for America.
You can do all that,
but without acting,
nothing happens.
You are the real deal.
Bridgette.
Uh,
thank you,
my friend.
I love you are the racist bigot of the day.
Then I will gladly be thrown in that bucket with you.
Uh,
you in case people don't know,
guys,
the link to rise is right down below and buy it and put it in libraries and all
that
to help us more on Bridgette.
And you can follow her on Twitter.
It's act.
Bridgette
[inaudible].